let's move on though more than a hundred
thousand royal male postal workers have
gone on strike in a dispute over pay
members of the communication workers
union said the two percent pay rise
imposed on them by management was not
good enough well i'm joined now by the
general secretary of the communication
workers union dave ward dave water very
good morning to you
first of all give us a sense of the size
and scale of the action that you're
taking today and the levels of
disruption it's likely to cause
sorry it's difficult to hear um yeah
sorry say that again
just wanted to get you to give me a
sense of the scale of the action that
you're taking today and the levels of
disruption it's likely to cause
yeah okay so there's a hundred and
fifteen thousand postal workers taking
strike action today it's the biggest
strike in the uk since 2009
um it's also probably the biggest
mandate that any union has ever had for
strike action over 97.7
members voted in favor of strike action
on a 77
turnout
our members are really really angry and
have lost all confidence in the
leadership of the company the company
made 758 million pound profit record
profits for royal mail last year they
gave away chose to gave away over 400
million pounds to shareholders they
rewarded themselves with huge record
bonuses apparently for achieving all
their financial targets and then they
imposed a two percent pay increase on
the workforce and against skyrocket in
inflation uh energy bills rocketing um
people are just not going to accept that
and i think that what's really a shame
here is that this is a group of workers
in the uk
that we would argue are one of the last
remaining pillars of our society they're
part of the social fabric of the uk
they have a fantastic relationship with
customers which is the company's
greatest asset
and it is unbelievable that the company
have chosen to treat our members in this
way so you know we're going to fight
very hard here
to get the pay rise that our members
deserve
well yes you say they're making record
profits royal mail says your proposals
would cost a billion pounds well it's
losing almost a million pounds a day
they say that
their business is suffering there are
fewer coveted tests being delivered for
example there are fewer people shopping
online post pandemic
and there's a steeply declining letter
market and they simply have to be able
to compete with with some of their
competitors so
that's reasonable isn't it
anna anna listen i i wish you could get
royal mal
to debate these issues and the statement
that you've just read out
because we would take that debate
anywhere any place any time and to point
out that it's a total fabrication of the
truth of what's going on in this company
and these people are being less than
honest with you less than honest with
their customers and and you know it's
just not on i mean they made record
profits
they have said that their bonuses
were achieved because they hit all of
their financial targets and yes there
are some issues we understand that
we will never face away from change it's
our union that wants to get on and do
the right change that protects the
company for the future but the company
has stood those talks we've got a second
ballot on change because they've walked
away from the agreement that we reached
with them and something that i've got to
raise today
that we wrote to the company about a
couple of days back we really do believe
that sitting behind this dispute the
motives for this company is that they
are involved at the moment in secret
discussions um on a takeover of this
company i'm bringing in one of these
the same type of scenario private equity
investment group in this case a company
called visa from luxembourg
and they are going to asset strip this
company they're going to abandon the
universal service and they want to turn
royal mail to make more profits for
themselves and the shareholders into
another gig economy employer and we are
not going to accept that
okay well we will certainly put that to
the company um in the meantime royal
mail will say that you've rejected a
deal you say it's two percent they say
it's 5.5 because they say that an extra
3.5 percent is is subject to agreement
on a series of changes so why are you
rejecting that
well that's pie in the sky and i'm sorry
to go back to the same thing it's simply
not true that was that offer as you call
it was put to our members directly by
the company uh before our members even
voted in the numbers that i just
described earlier on it is pie in the
sky the two percent was imposed two
percent of that is supposedly against a
productivity scheme that doesn't exist
and nobody in the company can sit in
front of anybody in the union and
explain what it is our members have got
to do to earn that two percent and the
other 1.5 of that is against a leveling
down agenda one of these piano style
leveling down agendas um which will
destroy the post office as we know it
royal mail as we know it and we're not
going to accept it i'm sorry to say
it's completely untrue what they're
saying to you and our members know that
postal workers would not be voting in
the numbers that they're voting in if
any of what you said was true but by the
way 5.5
even if it was there is not enough
against inflation and against the
horrendous energy bills that our members
and millions of other people in this
country are going to be facing
dave water we're likely to see a general
strike in this country do you think
would you back one if there was one
called
look i'm not here to talk about a
general strike what i will say to you
is that you know i think people across
the uk
every worker counts every worker's in
the same position
and yes i think we should be looking at
cold and hated action we should be
looking to raise
issues around the way that uk companies
are being run the blatant profiteering
that's taking place across the uk
because not only are the workforce being
ripped off here but also customers are
being ripped off these are the people
who are causing the spiral and inflation
that's going on and something's got to
be done
about the way that uk businesses operate
and royal mail is right at the top of
that list at the moment uh we've got our
sites on them you know it is time if
these people
are really only interested in further
profits for themselves then they should
resign from this company and get people
in who want to take forward this great
company that's been in existence over
500 years we'll deal with any change
we've accrued all change on technology
on automation so don't believe that the
stuff that they're putting out
and you know honestly get them on the on
the program with me uh with our union
and we'll debate all of those issues
live in front of the british public okay
we'll put that invitation to them we are
speaking to royal mail a little bit
later on but dave ward we appreciate
your time thanks very much indeed
thank you